cloud computing is internet-based
services for storage servers and
softwares providing scalability
flexibility cost savings and security
cloud computing refers to the data
stored managed and processed using a
network of remote servers hosted on the
internet instead of relying on a local
server or personal computer so why do we
need cloud computing cloud computing is
essential due to its ability to provide
scalable and flexible Computing
resources cost efficiency reliability
data security collaboration and faster
time-to-time Market with cloud computing
businesses can easily scale their
resources based on demand optimizing
resources allocation and accommodating
growth without significant
infrastructure changes the pay as you go
model reduces upfront Investments and
maintenance costs while ensuring High
availability through redundant data
centers Robo security measures protect
sensitive data and compliance standards
provide a secure environment cloud
computing facilitates collaboration and
remote work enabling seamless access to
Shared resources additionally pre-mill
services and tools accelerate Innovation
and reduce time to time Market allowing
businesses to focus on core competencies
and stay competitive to carry out
various Cloud processes several roles
are in action naming a few cloud system
engineer Cloud administrator Cloud
developer Cloud security analyst Cloud
automation engineer Cloud software
engineer and there is a huge list Cloud
professionals are high in demand and
gain competitive salary in the market
are you interested in knowing the salary
of a cloud professional then hey there
you are already watching simply learn
listen to the salary of a cloud
professional how they manage to grab it
in their own words
when I won the Grammy Award back in 2007
I saw that was it that was the highest
point in my life
I live in Georgia USA with my wife two
sons and two dogs
in 2006 I work as one of the producers
and writer for the short music video
Bena Mikasa esta Navidad
the video got me the Latin Grammy Award
in the best video category for the year
2007.
I shifted to the United States with my
wife and son in 2008 as a president with
special abilities
the first two years were really hard
there was no work to survive I have to
make some hard decisions so last year to
advance my career I made another choice
to upskill myself with simple learns
cloud computing bootcamp in association
with Caltech ctme simple learner's
course helped me make the switch and get
a new job with 100 salary hike
I got the job because of the AWS and
Azure technologies that I learned during
the course
so let me provide you with a small
overview of this Caltech cloud computing
bootcamp this comprehensive online
bootcamp course on cloud computing
enables you to acquire Mastery over
essential architectural principles and
develop the necessary skills to become
proficient Cloud expert become a cloud
Maestro with our engaging course that
covers a wide range of essential skills
from selecting the right cloud provider
and seamlessly migrating applications to
mastering performance testing and
managing Cloud workloads this course
equips you with the expertise to excel
become expert in identity access
management Auto scaling Disaster
Recovery web services API integration
and efficient Cloud migration and
deployment gain Proficiency in database
management multi-cloud deployment
strategies and harness the power of
storage Services a mark on your Cloud
journey and unlock endless possible
abilities in the world of modern
Computing with these necessary skills
you will also learn the tools like
Amazon ec2 AWS Lambda Azure container
service Azure functions elastic
Beanstalk virtual machines Amazon Dynamo
database and much more so what are you
waiting for grab the best career in
cloud computing with Caltech cloud
computing bootcamp find the course Link
in the description box so before we
begin with top 5 cloud computing career
in 2023 consider subscribing to our
Channel and hit the Bell icon to never
miss any updates from Simply learn so
the number one on the is Cloud architect
a cloud architect is responsible for
Designing and implementing a framework
within which all Cloud Technologies
operate their role extends to designing
the overall cloud computing strategies
of a company ensuring that all Cloud
performance aligns with the established
framework they play The crucial role in
facilitating the smooth functioning of
the company's Cloud infrastructure
guaranteeing efficient operations
adherence to budgetary constraints by
overseeing the cloud environment the
cloud architect ensures Optimal
Performance and seamless integration of
cloud services their expertise and
guidance enables the companies to
leverage the full potential of cloud
computing while maintaining the cost
Effectiveness and operational efficiency
due to the complex nature of their work
and their integral role within the
company Cloud Architects receive a
substantial average salary of hundred
and thirty thousand dollars moving
towards the next career in cloud
computing on the list which is cloud
developer Cloud developers create secure
Cloud applications in the global network
of cloud computing their role is similar
to the computer programmers and web
designers but with the focus on building
a hat proof programs and apps this
ensures protection against the cyber
attacks in the virtual infrastructure
they work with the salary range for
cloud developers typically Falls between
ninety thousand dollars two hundred and
forty thousand dollars reflecting the
high demand and value placed on their
expertise
administrator
these professionals have the
responsibility of managing a company's
Cloud infrastructure their tasks include
establishing Cloud policies aligned with
the security protocols developing and
maintaining employees access to cloud
services continuously monitoring and
safeguarding data stored in cloud and
evaluating the need for updates the
salary of cloud administrators can range
from sixty thousand dollars to ninety
thousand dollars with an average annual
salary of sixty seven thousand dollars
the number four on the list is cloud
automation engineer
the cloud automation engineer oversees
and implements automated systems for the
organization
Cloud automation Engineers encompasses
tasks such as constructing maintaining
and implementing automated systems this
technological advancements prove
advantages in minimizing the need of
Human Resources to engage in repetitive
tasks Cloud automation engineer earn a
decent average salary of twelve thousand
dollars which has the high potential to
increase as individual enhance their
skill sets and gain valuable experience
last but not the least on number five we
have Cloud engineer
the role of cloud engineer encompasses
full accountability for managing access
to organizations Cloud presence
additionally they handle negotiations
with vendors and clients to effectively
manage the cloud budget are reported to
have an average salary of 92 000 so with
this we wrap up top 5 best cloud
computing careers in 2023. if you like
this video share it with your friends
and don't forget to subscribe to never
miss any updates from Simply learn stay
tuned with simply learn till we meet
again thanks for watching this video
staying ahead in your career requires
continuous learning and upskilling
whether you're a student aiming to learn
today's top skills or a working
professional looking to advance your
career we've got you covered explore our
impressive catalog of certification
programs in Cutting Edge domains
including data science cloud computing
cyber security AI machine learning or
digital marketing designed in
collaboration with leading universities
and top corporations and delivered by
industry experts choose any of our
programs and set yourself on the path to
Career Success click the link in the
description to know more
hi there if you like this video
subscribe to the simply learned YouTube
channel and click here to watch similar
videos turn it up and get certified
click here